everybody likes going to the movies grab
a little popcorn maybe some candy then
just recline that seat and settle in
maybe you like comedies or maybe you're
a freak like gutfeld who's into horror
films
but ask any movie buff what they think
the greatest flick of all time is and
you're sure to hear the godfather
brought up plenty of times it's a
classic that explores one side of the
italian immigrant story of america and
contains some of the most famous lines
in movie history
i'm going to make them an awfully camera
fuse
fredo
you're my older brother and i love you
but don't ever take sides with anyone
against the family again family is a
major theme of the movie and one of the
best scenes is when we're introduced to
the five families of new york
and also the other heads of the five
families
new york new jersey
carmine corneo from the bronx
and
brooklyn
those crime leaders were just fictional
characters but they represented
something real
no not the actual five crime families of
new york
that gang represents the five families
of the democrat party
for the past two decades these clans
have used their power and influence in
the halls of washington to enrich
themselves and their offspring
last night we explored the suspect's
stock trades made by nancy pelosi and
her husband paul
but the family's suspicious business
ties don't just stop there
you see the apple doesn't fall that far
from the tree when it comes to paul
pelosi jr the 52 year old son of the
speaker of the house
the younger pelosi has reportedly been
linked to at least five business
entities under investigation by
authorities for alleged fraud
with reports going on to say paul pelosi
jr was hired by several firms that were
subject to both federal and state probes
and meanwhile has connections to a host
of fraudsters rule breakers and
convicted criminals although he has
never been charged himself
among the companies pelosi jr was
involved in was a database marketing
company called info usa which quote
was investigated by the iowa attorney
general's office several years earlier
for allegedly selling consumer data to
fraudsters
that company was founded by vin gupta
a major donor to bill clinton who had
been probed by the sec for allegedly
misusing company funds to fly bill and
crooked hillary around on private jets
but
doesn't just stop there for junior
pelosi or little pauly p p junior you
know these guys all have nicknames
according to the new york post in 2009
he co-founded natural blue resources an
investment company that the sec
alleged was run by convicted fraudsters
he was also tangled up in questionable
companies in 2013 and
2014 and later tied to a cryptocurrency
scam in 2015 quite a run
but while paul jr has been connected to
plenty of suspect businesses he has
never faced the same consequences as his
partners hmm i wonder why
i guess when your mother is a leader of
the democratic party you have a get out
of jail free card
and unfortunately it's not just the
house of representatives where family
circles are influencing decisions at the
highest levels
just on the other side of the u.s
capitol senate majority leader chuck
schumer has his own family drama last
week a senate panel approved an
anti-trust bill restricting big tech
platforms the legislation would stop
amazon google and others from favoring
their own products over competitors now
this legislation got worked hard in the
back room by lobbyists by the way which
lobbyists in particular
we'll get to that in a second
while this bill is moved through the
judiciary committee it has yet to get a
vote on the senate floor
you know who's in charge of bringing
this bill to the floor well
majority leader chuck schumer
and would chuck have any reason to delay
this bill
well maybe so you see
chuck's daughter jessica is a registered
lobbyist at amazon
according to new york state records so
chuck and his daughter are working every
side of the amazon bill
and chuck's son-in-law
michael shapiro worked at google's
sidewalk labs from 2017 to 2019. that's
according to his linkedin profile
and if that wasn't enough to raise some
red flag schumer's other daughter
allison
also works at facebook she's in
marketing
sounds an awful lot like the man in
charge of advancing big tech anti-trust
legislation in the senate has a huge
family interest in the process
now only a [ __ ] wouldn't see that
conflict
and it's not just the democrat leaders
of congress who are making family moves
in the white house papa joe's done
everything he can to take the stink off
his son hunter's fishy business deals
hunter's connection with ukraine well
documented here on fox we discussed last
night how hunters deals netted the biden
family
30 million bucks from chinese profiteers
linked to communist spies
and since his son was making money off
the communist country it's no surprise
joe biden was so quick to talk down the
china threat just a couple years back
china is going to eat our lunch
come on man
they can't even figure out how to deal
with the the the the fact that they have
this great division between the china
sea and the mountains in the east i mean
in the west
they can't figure out how they're going
to deal with the corruption that exists
within the system i mean
i you know they're not bad folks folks
but guess what
they're not a cut they're not
competition for us not to mention the
fact that biden completely swept the lab
leak under the rug
and we never found out where that
diamond went you know the diamond that
chinese tycoon gave hunter
that got swept away too
so while hunter was stacking bills
courtesy of america's biggest enemy
he was roping in another prominent
democrat family into his schemes
hunter's business partner chris hines
john kerry's stepson both in business
with china both fathers soft on china
and so another piece of the puzzle falls
into place essentially the chinese
government was funding a business that
co-owned with two of america's most
powerful democrat political families
so while biden and heinz sold out
america to make a quick buck their dads
were serving as vice president and
secretary of state respectively
but perhaps the single greatest abuser
of our country's trust lies in the hands
of bill and hillary clinton you remember
late 90s they established a non-profit
organization aptly named the clinton
foundation for years businesses and
foreign nationals funneled money into
the organization with some vague goals
to help others and perhaps they did do
some good but what really happened is
that when hillary clinton became
secretary of state fox reports at least
181 companies individuals and foreign
governments that had given to the
clinton foundation
also lobbied the state department when
crooked ran the place
181 companies
that's a lot of ious from the clintons
i wonder if she ever paid those favors
back
we're just asking questions
according to peter schweitzer's book
clinton cash in 2000 bill and hillary
clinton owed millions of dollars in
legal debt since then
they've earned 130
million dollars
i guess selling out america is a big
money business
the big guy ketchup paulie p the gavel
little chuckies
all of them wealthy well well-connected
and untouchable
it's not personal
it's strictly business
for these five leading democrat families
the money's never enough and so they'll
keep selling out america
as long as there's a buyer hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else